the Hong Kong police have seriously
changed their tactics they aren't
negotiating with the anti-government
demonstrators anymore now they're on the
attack as soon as they gathered Street
after Street tear gas and charges the
numbers of protesters on the street
seems smaller but the hard core keeps
turning out they build barricades and
cause disruption but they don't and
can't hold the ground for long please
I've had enough now only forward firing
as they're coming you gotta take down
these barricades smash down in the
crowds and our fleeing down the street
[Music]
this is going on for a long time now
police are not messing about
these types of incidents bring up
constantly and in minutes sending people
running for cover
others without a clue what to do break
it where can I say is there there's
powers and things that are open here and
like that who's going to get out back
and have it so I cannot go and feel like
the police are in no mood for
compromising protesters trying to escape
on the Underground are followed down
tear gas fight underground as well the
numbers of injuries are growing many
support the protest movement in Hong
Kong but disapprove of the violence in
the conservative North Point area from
our car we could see likely
demonstrators being dealt with by locals
they don't want them here the police had
to line the streets to keep the peace as
tensions rose throughout the day Hong
Kong has seen 10 weeks of demonstrations
and violence and more rallies over the
weekend often huge numbers turning out
to show their support but most of these
marches are focusing on police stations
and now the police are taking no chances
their deployments are in big numbers and
they're well armed and ready for trouble
but on it goes the Hong Kong and Beijing
governments are losing patience with his
disruption in effect it's having on the
economy and normal life the protest may
be faltering but they could just be
tired and so far there's not a single
sign of compromise on either side sturm
see Sky News Hong Kong